[Música]
hum
já o pessoal chama 1º bpm i
mas eu te falar que hoje é muito sério
eu escolhi entregar minha vida a um
sonho fazer com que a conta é e deixe
influenciar a expectativa de vida das
pessoas
não sei se vocês sabem mas aqui no
brasil hoje se você pega um grupo de
pessoas da mesma idade do mesmo gênero o
mesmo nível de escolaridade de mora no
mesmo bairro as pessoas negras têm
chances 23 15 maiores serem assassinadas
em relação às demais tristesse aqui isso
não é de hoje já fazem 518 anos que o
brasil é assim todos os dias
quem devia resolver isso é o congresso
mas apesar da nossa população tem 54%
das pessoas negras só 20% das cadeiras
do congresso são ocupadas por essas
pessoas
chegou um momento que eu achei que
simplesmente não havia mais solução até
que eu participei de um programa chamado
guerreiros sem armas que me deu muita
esperança
esse programa promovido pelo instituto
elos reúne jovens de vários países do
mundo pra passar por uma imersão onde a
gente aprende a cultivar comunidades a
realizar sonhos coletivos
lá eu aprendi um conceito do buckminster
fuller
na visão dele a gente não precisa ficar
forçando a mudar o modelo problemático
a gente pode simplesmente juntar um
grupo de pessoas e construir um novo
modelo
o modelo que faça mais sentido para a
gente em outras palavras se eu quero
fazer com que a cor da pele não
influencia mais na expectativa de vida
das pessoas e isso é um problema
nacional eu não vou ficar brigando com
os políticos atuais
a gente pode simplesmente juntar um
grupo de pessoas e construir uma nova
forma de fazer política
e é assim que a gente começou a
construir alguns movimentos no brasil
mas quando eu achei que a solução estava
eu confesso que deu uma esfriada gente
pensa bem no tamanho do brasil
pensem bem quanto às diferentes
comunidades existem dentro do nosso país
tem gente que é católico tem gente que o
evangelho tem gente roubando espírita
tem gente que é da classe política tem
gente que é da comunidade empresários
corajoso
tem gente que é da comunidade e
acadêmicos tem gente que nem estuda nem
trabalha
tem gente que gosta de cidade tem gente
que é da comunidade gosta da roça
tem gente que é da comunidade que não
tem dinheiro e tem gente que é uma
comunidade que simplesmente não sabe o
que fazer com tanto dinheiro como
cultivar comunidades tão diferentes para
realizar sonhos que são coletivos
foi assim que surgiu o movimento
acredito movimentos nacional
suprapartidário disposto a construir uma
nova forma de fazer política para o país
e aí sempre tem aquele que chega e fala
não se estão querendo construir uma nova
forma de fazer política
gente o brasil ele não convergem nada
todo mundo polarizado ninguém em quem
converge para uma coisa em comum em um
propósito como mentira a gente fez uma
pesquisa que revelou que 88 por cento
dos brasileiros acreditam que a educação
deve ser priorizada
então em pelo menos uma coisa a gente já
sabe que a gente concorda
vamos aproveitar e se construir um novo
uma nova forma de fazer política
mas a gente acha que simplesmente ter um
propósito comum talvez não seja
suficiente para cultivar diferentes
comunidades a gente sente que pelo menos
três pilares são fundamentais para fazer
com que a gente consiga reunir nosso
país e convergir na construção de um
brasil melhor mais justo com mais
igualdade de oportunidades
o primeiro deles é separar a mobilização
de organização e mobilização que
aconteceu em 2013
as pessoas foram para a rua bater panela
voltar pra casa todo muito organizado
se a gente tivesse organizado estaremos
teriam voltado para casa feito a reunião
de trabalho para analisar os próximos
passos formado lideranças para continuar
fazendo os movimentos a gente teria
criado estratégias para trazer
gente para os movimentos que estava
criando no país mas a organização não
foi suficiente para trazer exemplos
concretos
eu acredito está organizando pessoas em
14 estados diferentes
lá no acre a gente fez uma mobilização
para trocar o lixo do carro das pessoas
muda de planta
voltamos pra casa fizemos a reunião de
trabalho e definimos qual seria o
próximo passo
lá tem um auditório de cada 800 pessoas
em rio branco
nunca tinha sido lotado na história do
acre ea gente lotou e se a vitória em
uma conferência com 800 pessoas no acre
que acreditam que é possível construir
uma nova forma de fazer política
mas isso não a gente não parou por aí
voltamos pra casa e no ceará
a gente fez uma mobilização para incluir
dentro de uma escola uma menina trans
que tinha sido proibida pela diretora de
fazer a rematrícula simplesmente porque
ela era trans
essa mobilização envolveu mais de dez
partidos diferentes 800 pessoas de
maneira supra partidária em prol de uma
causa em comum
em são paulo a gente fez várias
revitalizações de praças a gente cortou
gramas a gente combater a febre amarela
e com ações concretas e organizadas
fizemos uma série de mobilização estamos
fazendo isso no país pra construir uma
nova forma de fazer política
mas nosso ponto de vista simplesmente
separar a mobilização e organização 11
talvez não seja suficiente para cultivar
a comunidade estão diferentes
existe um próximo passo que no nosso
ponto de vista é além de organização
tomar decisões a partir de valores não
tomar decisões a partir de pessoas ou de
ideologias os partidos tomar decisões a
partir de valores ea gente faz isso na
prática
um dos nossos principais valores é a
transparência radical
a gente acha que o movimento ele não
pode simplesmente falar como é que a
gente gasta o dinheiro
a gente tem que falar quem são cada uma
das pessoas que doam todos os dias para
fazer com que aquilo funciona na nossa
nosso ponto de vista não dá pra
construir políticas públicas que
aumentem a desigualdade do país
então um dos nossos valores é dignidade
de igualdade de oportunidades tudo que a
gente propõe precisa reduzir as
profundas desigualdades do brasil um dos
nossos valores ea diversidade
a gente só topa fazer renovação política
se a gente tiver pelo menos um terço de
mulheres e um texto de negros nessa
renovação
hoje esses números são de 20% e 14%
a gente precisa urgentemente aumentar
isso e é exatamente esses valores são
exatamente esses valores que estão sendo
capazes de reunir essas pessoas tão
diferentes têm um propósito em comum
para tomar decisões que são coletivas
agora então quando o movimento acredito
faz um encontro nacional
ninguém está preocupado se fulano do
partido a do partido b ou c o meu treino
nem gosta de partido
a gente quer construir um novo brasil
pautada em valores em comuns
isso vai muito além dessa ideologia
esquerda direita e por aí vai estar no
mínimo estado máximo a gente quer
construir um país pautada em valores
se fosse levado a sério eu não sei se
vocês sabem mas aqui no brasil existem
mais de 5 mil 56 mil vereadores a gente
dá para encher um estádio só de vereador
tem gente que queria jogar a bomba mas a
gente pode imaginar que esses pessoas se
elas fossem comprometidas
elas estariam fazendo encontros
nacionais dos vereadores do brasil para
tomar decisões comuns gerir os
municípios por mais que eles sejam muito
diferentes
algumas coisas incomuns poderiam
acontecer então e as decisões poderiam
ser tomadas juntas como os valores não
são claros
essas pessoas não conseguem se reunir e
além de organizar as comunidades separar
a mobilização de organização além de
tomar decisões pautadas em valores
eu sinto que a gente precisa de um
terceiro pilar do nosso ponto de vista é
adicionar a diversidade como valor
central da tomada de decisão
eu acredito ele só conseguiu chegar em
nove meses a 14 estados e ter mais de
dois mil voluntários fazendo com que
essa renovação política aconteça porque
a gente bateu o martelo e
colocou a diversidade no centro da
tomada de decisão já que a gente tem
comunidades são diferentes porque a
gente não pega então alguém que é
católica a evangélica betel banda
espírito porque a gente não pega então
alguém quer da comunidade políticos
empresários e acadêmicos mente tudo no
trabalho porque a gente não traz essas
pessoas para o nosso time gente jovem e
adulto gente velha elite negra gente
branca porque a gente não traz homem
mulher e compõe o time diversa
isso faz a gente toma decisões levando
em consideração toda a pluralidade do
brasil e isso faz com que a gente propõe
a projetos que realmente estão
conectados com a população e não esse
monte de coisa que um grupo de
iluminados decidirá em brasília e agora
tem que ser o país inteiro tem um caso
muito concreto que revela o quanto que
além de ideologia diversidade aumenta os
resultados a gente decidiu fazer uma
campanha do meu primeiro voto
a gente fez uma campanha para incentivar
jovens de 15 a 18 anos a tirar antes de
o eleitor votar pela primeira vez
gente eu ia nas escolas não tinha nada
que eu fazia que convencer aquele jorge
tirar o diretor nada podia dar dinheiro
que eles não iam até que a gente chamou
o jovem joão de 16 anos para trabalhar
comigo dentro do movimento e ele teve a
idéia brilhante ele falou cara a gente
precisa arrumar um jeito dos próprios
jovens conversarem com os próprios
jovens e ele sempre se toparem no
cartório coletivamente
e foi assim que fotos como estas
começaram a chegar o momento acredito
todos os dias os jovens uns convidando
os outros pra ir no cartório
coletivamente tirar o título de eleitor
antes eles não iam porque a experiência
chata mas antes imagina a gente você com
16 anos sair de casa duas da tarde no
sol quente por cartório pegar duas horas
de fila para tirar o título eleitoral e
nem é obrigado a votar melhor chance
agora se você com recebe o convite de
cinco amigos diferentes pra vocês
pegarem um ônibus junto passaram por uma
experiência coletiva se divertirem no
caminho ele lá no cartório tirar a foto
até com o diretor do cartório estava
fazendo isso fica mais interessante
isso foi o que a universidade fez com a
gente aumentou os nossos resultados e
fez com que o país avançasse mais porque
nós estavam sensíveis a isso
pra quem ainda não acredita
isso é uma coisa importante a maquis em
uma das maiores consultorias do planeta
fez uma pesquisa que revelou que
organizações que têm diversidade de
gênero tem resultados 21 por cento
superiores do que as organizações que
não possuem diversidade de gênero quando
a diversidade de raça e etnia
a adversidade sobe para 33 por cento o
aumento dos resultados
isso é uma pesquisa mundial então se a
gente realmente está comprometido com o
brasil precisamos colocar a diversidade
em todas as comunidades que nós já
estamos hoje não é apontar o dedo para o
outro falar agora você tem que ser
diverso é colocar a diversidade nosso
trabalho na nossa faculdade nos momentos
em que a gente se reúne para fazer
qualquer tipo de renovação e nesse
sentido eu queria fazer para vocês hoje
quatro convites
o primeiro é convidar vocês a começarem
a se organizar em pequenos grupos para
fazer com que os problemas complexos que
vocês enxergam sejam resolvidas
não precisa se preocupar em tentar
salvar o mundo e mobilizar 1 milhão de
pessoas em uma semana mas organiza um
pequeno grupo de pessoas que estão
dispostas a compartilhar desse sonho
coletivo e comecem a fazer pequenas
mobilizações assim como estamos fazendo
em todos esses estados para fazer com
que a organização seja bem resultados
maiores do que cada um dessas pequenas
mobilizações o segundo convite é fazer
com que vocês é convidar vocês às vezes
a exercitarem autoconhecimento e
descobrir em quais são os valores que
cada um de vocês
isso é o que vai fazer com que vocês se
conectam com comunidades que
compartilham dos mesmos valores que
vocês a gente entrar em comunidades
diferentes vai gerar conflito
eu não toco entrar nenhum grupo de
trabalho que a transparência não seja
radical porque se eu entro lá eu
descubro que tem alguns dinheiro vou
querer sair
então eu prefiro saber que esse é o meu
valor e eu prefiro procurar pessoas em
comunidades com valores similares aos
meus levem em consideração exercitem o
autoconhecimento para descobrir quais
são seus valores terceiro estejam
sensíveis à diversidade
se vocês estão em grupos de trabalho
hoje a diversidade não
o valor central existe um grande risco
das soluções que vocês estão criando não
serem soluções por tudo e serem soluções
só para as partes soluções para soluções
para a parte do brasil a gente já tem de
monte hoje isso é maligno
isso prejudica o nosso país levem em
consideração a diversidade estejam
sensíveis à ela e por último eu tô aqui
hoje depois de um ano mas cultivar
diferentes comunidades não é a coisa
mais fácil que tem que se fazer
tanto que é exatamente por isso que
aquelas 88% de pessoas que acredita em
educação ainda não se juntaram
mas o principal convite é que vocês não
desistiram de se organizar e comunidade
hoje é muito fácil vir aqui falar não eu
não vou votar em ninguém
eu não vou me juntar com ninguém porque
eu tenho certeza que ninguém vai
decepcionar
esse é o caminho mais fácil mas pros
tamanhos de problemas que a gente tem no
brasil as únicas soluções são coletivas
a gente precisa aprender a trabalhar
coletivamente pra conseguir resolver
problemas nacionais no nosso país
por último imagine um mundo onde se
organizar coletivamente e realizar
sonhos coletivos é a nossa norma
acredita que isso é possível de
acontecer porque se a gente está
imaginando isso ea gente está discutindo
aqui agora é porque isso já está
acontecendo
a gente ainda vai chegar um momento em
que sonhar coletivamente realizar sonhos
coletivos ea norma da nossa sociedade
espero que a gente esteja juntos
construindo isso essa é a idéia que eu
vim compartilhar
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]